cada vez son menos los que salen a votar
en Cuba el pasado domingo La Isla vivió
un proceso electoral sombrío cuando se
celebraban los comicios para elegir a
los miembros de la asamblea nacional
cubana Los altos niveles de abstención
ciudadana resaltaron en la jornada según
cifras oficiales la participación fue
del
68.58% del padrón electoral la más baja
desde 1976 además el 10% de las boletas
fueron anuladas al ser en su mayoría
papeletas en blanco el aumento en la
abstención de los cubanos es real sin
embargo desde el gobierno se desestima
el fenómeno Estoy seguro que va a ser
una excelente jornada que los candidatos
van a ser electos con un amplio apoyo y
que las elecciones cubanas van a seguir
siendo ejemplares y distintas los
índices de abstención se han elevado
desde el referendo constitucional del
2019 y el domingo llegaron a su pico
histórico el antagonista para Cuba
Estados Unidos ha reaccionado al
fenómeno el subsecretario del
departamento de estado para América
Latina criticó los comicios cubanos
cuando la única opción es el partido
comunista y comité cerrado se eligen
candidatos para postularse sin oposición
no hay democracia históricamente la
participación ciudadana en las
elecciones cubanas ha sido una de las
más altas del continente oscilando entre
el 80 y el 90% de la población saliendo
a emitir su voto sin embargo la crisis
económica y social que azota la isla ha
provocado que muchos cubanos demuestren
su malestar con la decisión de no salir
a votar